where you coming from um I just was at
Domino's picking up pizza and then I
grabbed them because she need a
ride what
that what was that
uh uh sorry I just got this truck
um I don't know these people I just pick
them up from down
I had are you doing Uber or something no
I I just they needed a ride get they
drunk and I was not so I
offered any alcohol to drink tonight no
uh like 6 hours ago or more and then I
took a nap
wait more than that probably 8 hours
ago and
insurance um
is that right sorry I just I literally
just bought this
TR I don't know what this is from
actually no you're I'm
sorry um what's a what's a good what's
the local address for you um well my
local my my current address here in
pulman is uh I have to look it up but
uh sorry are you taking them to Timber
yeah I I don't know them she just ask me
to take them here you you you're free to
leave I'm try to home yeah she she she
need she wants to go to here I want to
okay you're good you're good you're good
girl you can you're all good it's
okay I don't know man okay here wait
um sorry okay it's uh
Jesus is that a house uh it's an
apartment which one
uh yeah is it
a it's an apartment right for like which
apartment it's called
yeah what apartment do you live in
oh that's the
apartment was nice and phone
number
anything you might if iy check your eyes
real quick just make sure you're all
right to
drive it's to my
10 when you make to happy your Fe you
know like topal
h
I get
it let me buckle you up girl he's just
an
asshole I love you to
the Laura yeah so when was the actual
last time you had something to drink
like genuinely like uh probably 68 hours
for and I had two I had two selers like
a long time ago genuinely okay cuz your
eyes are telling me something else I
know I know well my eyes are always red
genuinely like I promise you I yeah so
so the redness is what made me question
whether or not you were you were sober
of course but then me actually looking
at your eyes is telling me that you
probably had something to drink a little
bit sooner than I I promise you I had
not but but like I understand that okay
would you be willing to perform some
voluntary field sobriety tests yes AB
all right do you have any physical
limitations that'll keep you from
falling tip of my pen with your eyes no
walk in a straight line or balancing on
one leg uh no okay I have my knees been
like that but that's it you guys are
good you guys are good I know we look
good when was the last time you had
something to eat or drink um I ate a
little
bit I ate a little bit of rice and
sausage about two hours
ago um and then I just picked up
dominoes but I haven't eaten any of it
yet all right so I'm going to run you
through a series of tests okay I'm going
to be evaluating you on not only how
well you perform the test but also how
well you follow my directions okay do
not start any of the tests until I've
instruct you to do so do you understand
all
right all right so again want you to
follow tip of my pin with your eyes and
your eyes only and do not move your head
do you understand yes yes all
right
sorry if I moved my head a little
s
[Music]
yeah
one more go
up so I'm going to ask you one more time
you very nice to me no no I ask you when
was the last time you you drank alcohol
about 6 to 8 hours ago genuinely have
you had drugs or narcotics since then um
just my my regular
uh and yeah no that's it that's it
today I think that's what it's called I
don't know are those supposed to mix
with uh alcohol you can but it's I
usually don't I mean like I didn't drink
a lot cuz
I I'm making sure my roommates are okay
and my roommates are back at the
apartment and I walked to the game and I
walked back to the game and then I took
a nap for a long time and I haven't
drank anything since then genuinely and
then I came back got dominoes that they
ordered and then I saw these girls at
Domino's and they were like can you
drive us somewhere blah blah blah and
then uh one of them wanted to be driven
here one of them wanted to be driving I
I think to the Ruckus she wasn't very
clear I think she's I don't know them
all right this next test is going to be
the walking turn okay so I'm going to
place you into What's called the
starting position you can just stay in
the same position that you were going to
S whenever you're ready okay thank you
and then um quick question you said with
my lead part that would be like
whichever's in front so want you to
start from that starting position that I
placed you in okay yeah this one yep
okay great all right
one 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 and then this way
and then is this my lead foot or is this
my lead
foot the exactly how I instructed you to
do great so one two 3 4 5 6 o 7 8 9
all right this next test is called the
one leg stand okay okay so I want you so
I want you stand with your heels and
Toes together arms directly at your side
and hold this position until I tell you
to begin do you understand yes okay when
instru over
this when instructed to begin you're
going to lift one leg of your choosing
holding your foot approximately 6 in off
the ground leaving your foot parallel to
the ground I want you to keep your leg
straight your arms directly at your side
I want your eyes on your lifted raised
foot and I want you to count out loud
1001 1,2 1003 and so on okay okay until
I instruct you to stop okay gra it ready
do you understand I do understand I
think me one sec I think I understand
all right got
it ready and begin 1001 1 2 13
1004 God I knew I would be said that 1 5
20078 1009 2010 2011 2012 2013 2014 2015
2016 sorry 2016 oh
1789 1020 1021
102223 end time thank you sorry no it's
all right like I said you've been cool
with me all right this next test is
called the preliminary breath test it
does not replace the evidentiary breath
test that we may take at a later time
okay are you willing to perform this
test yes all right all right on a second
you take a deep breath wrap your mouth
around that like you're blowing up a
wound just long steady breath okay got
it one second sorry there you good all
right deep breath then blow keep blow
blow harder hard you got to blow harder
than that okay yeah you got to blow out
yeah got it sry so take a huge breath in
and then just blow it all out as hard as
you can
keep going harder harder harder harder
harder harder harder harder harder
harder harder so you got to open your
teeth up open your teeth up actually get
it in there okay I'm sorry
sorry all right I'm ready this time guys
okay all right deep breath blow keep
blow blow
blow
perfect how's your guys's night going
not bad yeah not bad not bad is he
no yeah weirdly not yeah
I know my roomates were
like they were out driving earlier and I
was like you guys should be
driv you know what the legal limit is
Laura
0.8 8 that's what I meant that's and
you're
.12 okay so let me place you under
arrest for DUI okay turn you
back
sorry
[Applause]
all right sorry I know I don't have a no
it's all right I'll figure it
out let you know it is October 15th at
1219 a.m. we are being audio and video
recorded you have the right for make out
anything you say can be us
lawyer
you try to put them together
no go around
there going to go no
cuff all right Lura since you've been
cool with me we're just going to go no
cffs all right okay I'm I'm not like
that and then is that so that's your
vehicle correct okay is it okay if I
park it and lock it for you
okay the people in the car any dri like
I don't know them the one the passenger
seat definitely not yeah yeah that's
what I was saying the one that's
standing up definitely not either can
you give me a favor I I don't know if
this is like what I'm supposed to do but
like did you grab my phone it's in the
yeah yeah is there anything else out of
the car you'd like um no okay okay I'll
grab your phone out of there and then
I'll bring it down to him with the
station he's going to take you out and
then I'll get the car parked somewhere
okay thank you very much and then I'll
we'll let you know where it's parked
thank you very much I appreciate that
make sure it won't get towed yeah thank
you I mean there's not really worst that
could happen right now I mean you don't
want that insult injury right that's
fair yeah I've
um
yeah do you have anything on you those
sharp poker prick me uh just just just
let me know well I I I'm going to have
to search before put me on my car so you
out of the car you want your
phone yes I need my phone my wallet I
don't necessarily need I meanless I
unless I do need it but I I think it
would just be be better just to bring it
okay yeah my wallet should be in the
center console or like the side yeah
thank you so
much all right can you just face the the
vehicle for me all right place your
hands onto the vehicle well that's right
yeah that's all right all right using
the back of my hand yeah absolutely
you're you're
okay I can take this off too oh no
start I I I genuinely didn't drink
anything past like hours ago I'm
sorry
so you said you just met them tonight
yeah I well just yeah literally just
before this I was taking out food for my
roomat and then um they asked me for a
ride well your friend in the Jersey told
me that you were allowing her to drink
in the back on the way here and then she
was still drinking the corona I would
the one in the Jersey the one in the red
jersey oh she was in the front
she was I think so I must I don't know
if they swap the other one uh separate
your feet for me yeah sorry
um I didn't she had a open Bott in my
all right Laur you in the back of
my we her friend was crying to me and
she said she needed a ride and I
just oh I would not do that for future
thank you I appreciate that and then yep
you're you're good to go in okay and
then should I just I'll I'll get I'll
get that for you yeah just going to go
right on
top and these are the only things that I
got off you your ticket and this my
partner got your your phone and
everything
thank you very much thank
you your
left thank you yeah you're welcome
really appreciate
it
just pull it great I got sorry I got
nervous toward that brown
chair you just have a seat
there what's your name again offic St
Andre nice meeting you yeah you as
well I actually really appreciate you
being very kind to me and just like I
said I I feel the same
way
that's my fake one from a long time ago
obviously here my real ones in the
front that's I uh also probably an old
fake one that this one's really bad
too um it would be probably in the
front like this pocket
yeah that is also another fake one it
comes with
two there's my real ones in there though
this is a first
Laura yeah it
is I don't think so I oh there it
is there it
is I'm
deeply terrified right now we give me
one second we can talk through all of it
all right no it's fine I I understand I
genuinely
don't warning you under arrest for RCW
4661 502 or RCW
4661 504 driving or being an actual
physical control of a motor vehicle
while under the influence of
intoxicating liquor
[Music]
um further you are now being asked to
submit to a test of your breath which
consists of two separate samples of your
breath taken independently to determine
alcohol
concentration your now advised that you
have the right to refuse this breath
test and that if you refuse your
driver's license permit or privilege to
drive will be revoked or denied by the
Department of Licensing for at least one
year and your refusal to submit to this
test may be using a criminal
trial
further uh you are you are further
advised that if you submit to this
breath test and the tests administered
your driver's license permit or privil
to drive will be suspended revoked or
denied by the Department of Licensing
for at least 90 days if you are age 21
or over and the test indicates alcohol
concentration of your breath is 0.08 or
more or you are in violation of 4661 502
driving Under the Influence or RCW 4661
504 physical control of the vehicle
Under the Influence or under age 21 and
the test indicates alcohol concentration
of your breath is 0.02 or more or you
are in violation of RCW 4661 52 driving
Under the Influence or RCW 4661
54 physical control of the vehicle Under
the Influence if your driver's license
permit or privileged to drive is
suspended revoked or denied you may be
eligible to immediately apply for
ignition interlock driver's license you
have the right to additional test
administered by any qualified person of
your own
choosing all right this signature is
saying I have read or have had read to
me the above statements
okay yes I
have will you now submit to a breath
test um
yeah but can I ask you a
question
uh like I understand that but like
uh this is kind of a dumb question is
this is
it a bad idea it's a good idea to submit
to a breath tester so I cannot give you
yeah I guess you can't tell me right but
what I can do is I can get you in
contact with an attorney and you can
speak with them about
it
okay you want to do
that I guess I don't know you're you're
an American citizen lawyer you have
every right to speak with an attorney I
know I just I know I I fucked up it's
just
like it's just weird I I don't really
know what to do so I I would feel more
comfortable if you spoke to an attorney
because you're kind of unsure about what
the process is and where we're at and so
I would I would rather have an attorney
explain that to you all right does that
sound like a good idea let's do that um
do you have a specific attorney that you
would want to speak with if if not then
we can call is that okay which part uh
the second I I don't my family's
attorney um passed away so I don't have
this speci and I I only ask that you
don't have to have one I only ask that
just in case but we have public defend
at our on call that we can contact for
you yeah let's do that so we're going to
hop up and we're going to go right into
that room right behind
you thank you yeah you're
welcome no look good
um
so he said and I also agree um that I
should consent to test okay I kind of
was thinking about doing that anyways
but I just didn't know I don't know like
I said I I understand um I'm just now
going to I'm going to ask you again will
you now submit to a breath test
okay what does your tattoo me this oh
that's my wife's initial
a it's very
sweet all right I just got to do a mouth
check just to make sure you don't have
anything in your mouth just open your
mouth nice and
big move your tongue to the left and
right all right let's make sure we keep
our hands in our lap from here on
out I'm used to having to do that for
the dentist I don't know oh okay that
was this is
weird I just a very anxious person
that's
all you don't seem like it really yeah
I'm I'm trying so hard you're doing very
well you know I'm just trying to be
respectful yeah no you've you've already
been extremely
respectful I I I understand the
circumstances I
just I just didn't
um
it's been a very difficult couple of
weeks
so I'm sorry toar off no no it's
okay I also think that I haven't really
processed anything that's happening I'm
just kind of
going for you to say that you're anxious
and the way that you're acting now I I
would probably second up really yeah
that's shocking I know I'm like panic
attack inside right now but I try really
hard to keep it in um I'm a big people
person and I've worked with people
through most of my life I've worked in
restaurants since I was 12 so I can
usually I don't know I enjoy people but
I
just I don't know this is obviously a
first for me I've never gotten in any
trouble ever hopefully it's a last too
oh
absolutely now you legal yes
sir I know I know jeez I
know and the best part is I have
not used them since I was in San Diego
which was 2 years
ago I
obviously you can throw them away but I
understand that that's a I can't throw
them away okay keep them for evidence
that's
okay um yeah you you will not be going
to
jail
um and you can only stay in here for a
total of 6 hours okay um so after we get
done with this I'm going to place you
into one of the holding cells and then
I'm going to have to go back out because
it sounds like the rest of my partners
are getting a little bit busy out there
I'm not shocked um
it other other up until this there is
like nothing so I'll be here for like 6
hours yes at at the absolute most okay
um and then we'll release you from here
with all your paperwork thank you
yeah
all right like I said this is going to
go into your
property and clean this top up let's go
to I'll grab you a
blanket
thank you really appreciate
it
sign right
here sure you're to sign it here saying
that these are your
fingerprints
Sor so it usually prints your
fingerprints right here but as you can
see it prints
the the right four fingers and since we
weren't able to scan those it's not
going to actually be on there thank
you
o sorry it's not really going to be the
same that's it for
that
do you have any questions before we get
into all your paperwork
thank you for
asking
okay
so went over
before uh your request for DUI
hearing your breath
results this
mine so this is just saying that you got
all the things back that I removed off
of you earlier
tonight
uh the notice of hearing which is going
to
be
tomorrow 16th 3 p.m.
and
cax okay and then here is your criminal
Citation for the DUI and then the three
driver's
licenses all right yes sir um this goes
along this is a mandatory court
appearance that goes along with this yes
sir you have any questions for
me
[Music]
um so you're your truck is parked at
Chase
Bank all
right okay
yeah thank
you so if you have any questions for me
you are free to go and I hope you have a
better day and I hope
the phone call
wasn't too
bad I it's my own feel it is it is um
it's tough cuz like I said I I have two
girls and like I would 0% be happy with
some with something like this and I I
would be extremely upset
um but I done this quite a few
times
and I can tell that
you are regretful of Your
Action
um like I would be thoroughly
surprised if this happened again to
you where's a lot of people that I've
done this with I would not be Sur
surpris
um and you you definitely
care which is apparent um but it's it's
not over right you're still
young um you have plenty of life and
Time ahead of you just the biggest thing
from here on out is to make sure that
this is the last time absolutely because
obviously you need to be able to say
that like this happened but it just
happened one time it wasn't a it there
there was no pattern to it that is
really the the biggest thing from from
here on I just making sure there's no
pattern okay I really appreciate you
saying that
I I appreciate
that thank you yeah you're
welcome and if you have any questions
you
can call um the the the the courthouse
will also be able to answer questions
probably better than than I
will
yeah you have a better day
thank
do I just have to call
someone
like so so the door the door is right
here and like I said your your license
isn't suspended right now yeah um so
you're you're still free to
drive
um at this point I would recommend if
you could have somebody pick you up I
would purely because you haven't even
slept yet yeah that's kind of what I was
thinking yeah um uh so you can you can
hang out in our lobby is that okay yeah
as long as you need thank
you
yeah you as well yep right there thank
you very much please
push